I spent a lot of time telling people you
know what a bad guy you are
thank you are doing something very nice
very cool to help out local Los Angeles
restaurants right now once you tell us
what you're doing yes well I will say
well I started because again I am an
extreme extrovert and have to get out so
and I knew a bunch of local restaurants
here in the valley where I live and and
they were still open and so I just I
just started filming myself outside of
the restaurants with fully naked no I
and I would just say hey go to go to a
tuning fork here in Studio City it's a
great gastropub and and and then and and
promote them and then and this is for
take-out this is for take you know
obviously you can't go in yeah and
they're all still working they're all
being very sanitary
except for one and I won't tell you who
and then it's very dangerous there no
and then Melissa McCarthy name-drop Ben
Falcone name drop October act oh they
contacted me and said hey that's really
cool you're doing we just talked to
Octavia Davis and again name drop and
Octavia Spencer dear God
sorry what up [ __ ] okay anyway they
were like she's been feeding hospitals
and wit by buying meals and we should
combine powers and get money from those
independent retro or get food from their
pay those restaurants and then serve
hospital staffs who are obviously
overworked and so then we were start
trying to start a free I like a
non-profit and then we heard about this
thing called frontline foods which
they've already got a huge
infrastructure they're already doing it
and we just kind of joined forces with
them and that's why I'm talking about it
now and I it they're in many cities and
so these there are so many independent
businesses that are gonna go down and
even with government help which is great
but they're still they're gonna there
are so many people are gonna lose their
jobs and they're not paying rent right
now which is great but soon as this is
over
they're gonna be on the hook for it so
anything anybody can do out there to
support your local restaurants or any
local business like that you definitely
should like Conan you should definitely
have another bus of like one of the
Roosevelts maybe put in FDR there you
know you could doing my part I've been
going to hospitals and shouting
monologue jokes through the open windows
oh I've been arrested six times
apparently that was a terrible idea well
but it it's not really giving back I
thought it was I thought it was I
thought I heard that laughter was the
best medicine so that's what I did and
then it turned out that it's it's
terrible idea the jokes weren't good my
delivery was off and you at this even
after five times you thought I'm gonna
do it again I'm gonna try again I'm
tenacious when it comes to giving okay
well you you should support your local
independently owned businesses I think
that's a better way to go yeah don't do
what I was doing